hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV i am at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and pleased to
be joined by Bob corrector who's the
director of the socio nomics Institute
and a long time investment guru what is
socio nomics and what interest does that
have to all of us associate nomics is
something I've been developing for about
25 years and it's a theory of social
causality most people default to
mechanics or physics when they think
about how society changes and why it
changes for example most people would
assume that the mood of the country or
the population is due to events some
politician makes a speech and that makes
people feel good or feel bad or a war
starts and makes them very afraid or
piece breaks out and so everybody's
happy or a recession begins and makes
everybody worried my idea is the
complete opposite causality I think
there are such things as waves of
socially move their endogenously
regulated they happen when people
interact together and these waves are
essentially polar between positive and
negative mood and as mood wax is more
positive people take certain approaches
to social action there'll buy more
stocks and they'll become more
productive and the economy improves they
listen to happier music they wear flashy
ER clothes and when the mood is negative
and trending in the other direction they
tend to sell stocks they tend to be less
productive we get recessions and
depressions and they wear more somber
colors I was actually proposed by
University gentleman back in the 20s and
then a guy in the 60s named Ralph ratna
sort of brought it back to the foreign
he said you know when stock prices are
near top skirt lengths are very short
when they're near a bottom there long I
don't think that's just data fitting
luck I think that is a way that females
express their
you know frivolity and so on when
they're feeling in a positive mood and
get more somber and expressed that
visually than they're in a negative mood
if I did notice they did their research
when skirts were short both times I
think that's what woke them up your
interest in this is its intellectual
it's self interested as someone who's
trying to figure out how to make maximum
money in the market what's what is your
angle on it's it's it's an intellectual
pursuit the socio nomics Institute
doesn't make any money we do have
subscriptions and we put a lot of work
into what we do we've had one paper
published in the Journal of behavioral
finance we've got another one that's
currently at a journal and it's about
the relationship of the preceding stock
market movement to re-election prospects
and we went back 200 years we did the
entire data started out with George
Washington's reelection campaign in 1792
checked all of them we found extremely
high correlation between the one two
three or four years stock market
movement prior to a reelection and the
outcome of that reelection we tested
unemployment the inflation rate GDP all
of them were weaker in fact the
inflation rate and unemployment had no
statistical see david's significance now
unemployment data only go back to
nineteen forty-two hardly get
significance the others go all the way
back two hundred years so we had all of
those two tests and of course my view is
that if social mood is truly the driver
the stock market should be a better
indicator than economic figures because
the economy lags the stock market people
for example when mood becomes more
positive they can buy stocks very
quickly they can respond to that mood
right away they press a button to call a
broker and instantly that investment
doesn't really show up without ability
for companies to raise money easier
doesn't necessarily change the few
months yeah if a CEO makes a positive
decision you can't affect at that moment
as a trader can he might have to have a
meeting borrow money get his people to
agree get an advertising campaign going
get more inventory you buy another
building who knows but those things take
time and that's why recessions the
bottom about three to six months after
the stock market does and the economy
tops after the stock market does I think
that's the reason for so tell us Oh
person who look
guru guru where are we now in this kind
of doldrums recession that's not quite a
recession in terms of that metric of
kind of mood wave I think waves of
social mood fluctuate in a fractal form
that the form is D is delineated by what
we call the elliott wave model was
developed by a man named erin elliott in
the 1930s and it's hierarchical so that
there are smaller waves or components of
the next larger and the next larger and
so on according to the work that we've
been doing in fact according to all the
people have been using the model since
Elliot himself in 1934 the peak that we
saw in 2000 / 2007 is one of the biggest
we've had in a long long time it's more
important than the top in 1929 we think
it's equivalent to what England had at
the South Sea Bubble peak in 1720 so
this was a period of extreme optimism by
many many measures for example dividend
payouts and stocks or the p/e ratios
percentage of cash and mutual funds
dwarfed anything that had ever been sown
optimism is translated on that stock
level which is what you exactly so that
was fairly the population actually the
population inflected it in many ways as
well I mean you know you had to come
back of bubblegum music and boy bands
and that whole thing just as you had the
English and baby British Invasion
mid-60s you know those are major peak
phenomena and you don't get those at
major love so that extreme optimism was
a message to us saying this is a major
time when you have extreme optimism you
don't keep going you start looking for a
reversal and we've seen one of the most
important manifestations of that
optimism was the extreme growth in death
the creditors believe they be paid
eventually in the debtors thought they
could pay it off and that's beginning to
have consequences that extreme optimism
has consequences because most of that
debt is now in trouble and that is part
of the basis so-called fundamental basis
along with the change in psychology that
we think is developing has been
developing since 2000 / 2007 toward the
negative pole of social mood so we're
heading down that slope and you can see
it manifest in
a lot of ways some debt isn't being paid
you're seeing unrest in many portions of
the world we're saying protests the
United States regime changes the Middle
East we're starting to get that bubbling
boiling feeling that kind of reminiscent
of the 30s or the 70s and that's the
environment we're heading into and so do
you is this the kind of thing that can
last another decade or another two
decades or you know is for sure to some
kind of oil and there's no since it's a
fractal form it's not really tied to
specific time lengths sometimes these
things drag out over a long period of
time sometimes they're very very Swift
we had a really fast crash in 1929 1930
two is fewer than three years but the
sideways sort of playing out period
really lasted about 20 till 1949 lots of
may have in that period Hitler took over
Germany Stalin starved people in the
Ukraine Mao took over in China really
rotten stuff was happening and in the
decades that followed the mood was so
positive we had peace treaties around
the world we had the UN cooperating and
had apologies among major religions and
amazing things happening in the 80s and
90s that was the positive peak and now
we're heading back in the other
direction probably lasted a while but
sometimes their rapid crashes and other
times they're just very long playing out
periods such as Japan's been
experiencing since 1989 so final
question before we go what should we be
looking at what are the preliminary
indicators of where we are in this
moment of the preliminary indicators
worthy were the periods of optimism and
the things people were doing to express
it so it was in 2002 and I wrote a book
called conquer the crash saying there's
so much optimism that we're going to go
the other direction for a while it's
built up so much debt that's a serious
problem I brought a very bullish book
along with AJ Frost in 1978 when
everybody was doing gloom and all the
books were negative mood said no this is
the signs of a low we're going to have a
probably a Roaring Twenties type thing
and even what happened was way bigger
than we thought I thought the dad would
get all the way to three or four
thousand it's been rough first four
years of that books a reception
yeah wrightson didn't bottom 282 and I
think my conquer the crash book was
probably about four years early because
real estate can top out till 06 but we
saw the preliminary things and most
people extrapolate linearly and we
extrapolate according to this fractal
model it's completely different so when
other people see all these things they
put out books like real estates the way
to get rich forever and property you can
you can to get rich too and stocks are
going to see 36,000 was one yeah 40,000
I was a hundredth of that right and they
were all near the peak and so we put
those up as examples of optimism and why
we were very bearish we were the
opposite we were pessimistic about the
future but I'm a few years less
pessimistic because things have gone
down real estates down forty five
percent commodities are down forty
percent stock to the bond about 20-25 so
we're heading in that direction and at
some point I think we're going to see
people hate stocks and say they'll never
buy a plot of land again the rest of
their lives and being one of the
greatest biking opportunities of all
time when everybody else is negative we
hope so so we'll just wait for you to
write your next book and then four years
later it's going to kick into my whole
life's been one cycle I got in the
business in 1975 and I'll probably
retire about the time we hit bottom the
old days you get a cycle every four
years it was a lot of fun so if I minute
long enough maybe I'll write one more
Booker and say this is a good time to
buy thanks to your brother that's great
well thank you very much Bob Proctor
socio nomics for reason TV I am Matt
Welch
you